yesterday I participated at the European
Council meeting it was a long and
intense discussion among European
leaders and after which we passed a very
clear message that the European Union
and the Member States will do everything
they can everything necessary to
overcome the coronavirus crisis and we
will do it together in solidarity for
the benefit and protection of our
citizens for that we're taking measures
and measures needed first to limit the
spread of the virus and to provide
urgent assistance to those in need in
the case of the European external
actions this is devoted to our citizens
stranded in third countries to return
home this is an absolute priority we
have more than 400,000 people that want
to go back home
more than 150,000 has already done it
thanks to the air flight that we have
been all the Member States providing
them and more than 2,000 by the European
Union civil assistance use for the
extreme cases where there is no
commercial or chartered flight we have a
task force here in the European Union
external Action Service which is working
around the clock to assist Member States
we are reaching out to third countries
organizing repatriation flights ensuring
landing rights and access to our space
transit access an extension of visas
when needed there is a big problem today
with the access to the air space many
countries are closing it and we have to
ask them to provide an extension of this
closing in order to
allow many more flights to take people
back home we need to limit the spread of
the virus
to promote research so that we can
quickly find a vaccine that would
believe for the benefit of the entire
world here cooperation is much more
needed that competition also you have to
tackle socio-economic consequences this
crisis has created a most urgently to
ensure the provision of medical
equipment the Commission in cooperation
with industry will provide an overview
of stocks production and imports and
take actions to improve the situation we
will also actively pursue its giant
procurement initiative and increase the
initial budget of the strategic European
Union stockpile of medical equipment
especially for intensive care vaccines
and therapeutics in parallel also member
states are supporting each other for
example France Germany and Austria
together are sending 3.5 million masks
and 800,000 protection dresses to Italy
and some member states are taking care
of each other patients to ensure a
hospital capacity for crew solidarity
and support to our partners around the
world is welcomed because solidarity and
international cooperation are at the
heart of a collective success we will
continue working hand-in-hand with our
partners around the world to this end in
Europe we are very grateful for all
genuine offers of help coming from
partner countries from all the world
from the private sector whether in the
provision of maths or other medical
equipment what is important that the
people in need
the necessary help we are promoting
coordination in multilateral fora in the
g7 and in the g20 working with United
Nations and its agencies the Red Cross
we have mobilized 300 million euros to
support partners in combat individuals
around the world channeling this help
through the World Health Organization
for example at the institut pasteur in
that car we are looking in particular at
africa because we want to underline that
we will not forget about our system
continent when addressing this global
pandemic we cannot look only to the
problems in Europe because the problems
in other regions will be sooner or later
also our own problems that why we must
act collectively and the global level we
are playing a role the European Union is
playing a role in doing everything
possible to tackle this crisis and it
consequences is now that we have to
demonstrate that European and global
solidarity really means solidarity can
not be just a word that we use without
any kind of commitment solidarity has to
be proof on facts president underlined
rightly said that history is looking at
us and that Europe needs to act with one
big heart rather than 27 different ones
globally these unprecedented events call
for an unprecedented international
action to master this crisis that we are
going to face and win jointly